dr anthony fauci is at least partially
blaming fox news host tucker carlson's
comments about him for the threats that
he and his
family have been receiving and this is
another really great opportunity to
revisit the concept of stochastic
terrorism which sadly shockingly
is quite prevalent during the trump
administration now you might recall that
we learned
a few weeks months ago about threats
against dr
anthony fauci which is crazy usually we
listen to doctors during pandemics in
the united states they need security
and the threats have in fact gotten so
bad that even
dr fauci's family including his
daughters are needing security now i
talked about that last week or the week
before
well tucker carlson has been saying
anti-fouchy
things for some time saying that dr
fauci
is quote an oily politician on an ego
trip tucker claimed masks don't do
anything
tucker's against shutdowns trucker
tucker
trucker tucker has cl he should be a
trucker rather than a fox news host i
think we'd get actually a lot more value
given the importance of trucking rather
than him seeding the country with
bad information he could be
participating in delivering key supplies
but no i meant tucker not trucker
claiming dr fauci has been quote
enjoying himself
during the pandemic and on and on and on
carlson
also claimed that the policies dr fauci
was recommending
were national suicide it's a very long
list
dr fauci was asked about it he was
interviewed by the washington post
recently
and dr fauci said quote i'm not
concerned
about what he carlson says i think you
could say that when he does that
meaning talk about fouchy it triggers
some of the crazies in society to start
threatening me
actually threatening which actually
happens
who would have thought when i was in
medical school doing things to save
people's lives
i'd have to be going around with a
security detail
that's really ridiculous yeah
it does trigger people when tucker
carlson
makes dr anthony fauci the target of his
attacks and the relevant term is one
i've used before
it's stochastic terrorism people often
ask how do you spell it that's
s-t-o-c-h stochastic
terrorism this type of rhetoric on fox
news
can have a real world impact we we
already
see the real world impact in that dr
fauci and his family
now need security but it could lead to
an actual acute incident if you
understand what i'm saying now
of course of course tucker carlson
wouldn't be
legally liable even if it was proven
that someone attacked fauci
and got the idea from watching tucker
carlson why well number one tucker isn't
saying
go attack dr fauci but number two
when we say stochastic terrorism we're
talking about the idea that
given a large enough audience it starts
to become mathematically likely
that someone will be moved to action by
the things that you say
on the show right so let's take
something very benign
if i on on the show every day say it's
really important that people vote
this election no matter what if my
audience is 10 people
it's not super likely someone is going
to go and vote who otherwise wouldn't
have
because of me my audience is a hundred
people it starts to become more likely i
will have influenced someone to go and
to vote who otherwise wouldn't
my audience is a hundred thousand it's
now mathematically very likely that by
suggesting
people vote i will have influenced
someone so
let's apply it to these situations
imagine that there's a really
small chance that tucker would be able
to get an
individual viewer in his audience to go
and try to kill dr fauci imagine that
the possibility of that is
0.00001
or something like that if tucker's
audience is 10 people
it's extremely unlikely with such a
small percentage that anybody is going
to hear tucker
and go and attack dr fauci when the
audience is a hundred
or a thousand or a million millions of
views on youtube
it's still not going to be many people
but the probability
that one person goes and tries to harm
dr fauci based on what they heard on
tucker carlson's show
starts to become greater than one like
it's likely to actually affect at least
one person
and as you can see once the audience is
big enough
the irresponsible suggestion that i
could make
or that tucker carlson could make or
whatever starts to be
likely to have a real world impact we
saw it with glenn beck and the tides
foundation years ago
where glenn beck was ranting and raving
i think at the time he was on fox news
about the tides foundation
and a guy an armed guy was actually
pulled over i believe it was on the
california highway on his way to attack
or bomb or do something to the tides
foundation now of course glenn beck was
not legally liable
but the guy said i got the idea that the
tides foundation needs to be dealt with
from glenn beck
is it easy to say well that's clearly
somebody who's mentally disturbed
normal people wouldn't do that sure but
the point is this stuff really matters
and for everybody who says merely free
speech and freedom of the press and all
of that yeah that's right
no one's denying tucker has the right to
say things about dr fauci
the same way that i have the the the
right to say people should go and vote
what i'm
saying is you have to use your speech
responsibly and you have to understand
that when you start throwing violent
attention on a doctor trying to deal
with the pandemic
you place a target on that individual
you're throwing gasoline on the fire
quite simply
and it's not about limiting speech
that's not at all what this is about
it's about recognizing that we have to
use
our platforms responsibly and of course
it's not just tucker right i mean if the
country were more educated
if the country less easily fell for
anti-science nonsense
tucker would be yelling into an empty
well but unfortunately
the american right is a particularly
receptive audience
for anti-science nonsense if you've been
watching the show you've probably heard
me talk about how much i love my helix
mattress well i was really excited to
hear that helix has launched
a new company called all form which
makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs with the
same level of quality
and comfort that i expect from these
guys and all form is one of our sponsors
today
they're giving you twenty percent off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put in my living room at home
it's now
my favorite piece of furniture in the
house
it took me just minutes to set it up
it's solidly built it's
huge it's roomy it has a modern
minimalist design which i love but it's
also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality it has become the
focal point of my living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it
and the best part is everything comes
with a lifetime warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now and get 20 percent off your entire
order when
you get there by going to all form dot
com slash pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video